all right this is the very first video I
will ever recorded on this camera thanks
to Sam macaroni for giving it to me and
I'm here with my dad
Gloria's Bernie my beautiful niece my
wonderful stepmom and I don't know what
else to say I guess I'm gonna start
vlogging up I don't even know about it
okay Cindy you can turn the tv back on
it's my sister that's got a recording
capability built-in unlike other camera
who don't yell you know it's just a good
camera that's small and you can keep in
your pocket but very but other cameras
other cameras have do they recorder
sounded oh dear yeah but you don't want
to do this kind of thing on your cell
phone cuz I know it's not really bad cuz
cellphones okay the camera you gave
me a camera hey Carrie gave me for
Christmas about 4 or 5 years ago that I
still use and enjoy would that be work
for videos papa if that one would - yep
how close would that be in terms of
finished results of what you get from
this ah I don't know all I know is that
Roman Atwood uses the same camera for
his vlogs ok ok and then brother having
rules they're talking of is that is that
mr. bean
I'd like to be involved tell Sophie what
it was why just my friend who's a
YouTube legend um dad and Miss toka it
is him for the first someone else mr.
bean is rolling something rolling it
robin atkin start yeah I guess I don't
know all right well this I guess this is
rocky yeah yeah all right